視聴者からの質問の方で
偏差修査について面白い質問があったのでちょっと読ませていただきたいです。
はい。はい。
私は一般に言われる偏差に分類される人間だと思いますが、どっちかやっとスクールの方の教育感や主張には同意する部分も多くあると感じています。
で、日本を停滞させてきた人間が偏差値
を超えるようなそうではなく、むしろ偏差値
50から65
程度のいわゆる偏差値修とは言えないそうなのではないかということについてはどうお考えですか?偏差取材という言葉について当者としてや括されてる印象を受けるため表現についてもご一向いただけますと幸いですっていう質問なんですけど
うんそれはね彼がね共満なんよ傲はええことなんよ
[音楽]
うんふん
ちゃんとできるから傲慢なんやで
もせんのにいっとるのは共満なんやから
本人まず自分が優れとるということを行動
で示してみろよ。なぜ偏差修催がいかんか
と言うと教育の失敗者なんや。教育は
地区育体育
やろ。地区の目的は
論理的思考力[音楽]をつける
論理的思考能力を養うことなんや。ところ
が偏修というのは物覚えのえい人[音楽]
や。だから自分は偉いんだと思い込んじむ
物覚えがええということは人の意見を盗ん
どるということやだから実際に行動して
自分で作った意見やないもんでも脆ろいわ
な。しかも自分の言っとることを自分で
できんやろ。そこがいかん。得意区。得意
やったか?得意育って何なんやねん。得意
[音楽]区は人間性を高めることだ。だっ
たら人間性って何なんや?それをどのよう
な方法で高めるんだ?それを言ってみ。
例えばね、論語なんかが非常にいいのは
リーダーもの。偉くなる人。中国は役人の
あれやからね。過去ので偉くなるんやから
。ので偉くなった人がリーダーになっても
ええのかということやね。論語を読むと
分かるのはのことは何つ書いてないんやで
。みんな得意のことを書いてあるんや。だ
[音楽]からリーダーの1番の要素は人間
性の高いこと。これが1番の要素なん。だ
から自分の人間性が高いということを証明
したらええんだ。ただしどのようにして
高くなったかを言えよ。トレーニング法が
分かっとるのかから[音楽]体育体育やっ
たの?今の学校では体育やってないよ。今
の学校でやっとんのは体育と消して
スポーツをやっとるんだ。体育とスポーツ
は全然目的が違う。だから体育をちゃんと
やってないんだから行動力はない。体育の
目的は正しい行動をすることなんや。少年
と一緒で。だから体育をちゃんとやって
ないやつは正しい行動ができんよ。
修催君はどの部分で優れとるんだ?
反論でありそうなのが暗記ばっかりじゃなくて、ま、一定の大学レベルになると論述とかしっかり論理的思考を試されるような問題もあるのかなと思うんですけど、これについてどうですか?
[音楽]
うん。だからそん時はもう遅いやろ。小さい時にそれができるんやから。だから小学校のうちから思考能力を高めとかないかんのや。
あ、なるほど
ね。うちの娘がアメリカの大学に行っとる
時にどんなに論文を出しても自分としては
最高の論文だと思って出すんやけど週に1
回ずつ論文出さないいかん。全部落とされ
たダメでどうしたらええだろう。ちょうど
その時俺が刑務所に入っとったもんでさ、
刑務所に手紙が来るんだ。どうしたらええ
でしょうな。もう簡単にや。聞いてみい
よって何が悪いのか。本人が聞いたらその
教授[音楽]はね、あなたの意見はどこに
あるんですって言ったんや。みんな人の
意見を映しただけやないか。そんな論文
通すわけにいかんて言われて、で、それ
から自分の意見を書くようになったら全部
通ったっていう、それがな、アメリカ人の
教育の仕方やないか。叶うわけないやろ、
日本が。思考能力はトレーニングしてない
。今考えるコンピューターを作ってそれを
教育に取り入れるというやろ。バカなこと
言うんやね。最初に答えもらってどうする
んやな。自分で答えを出してそれをあれと
合わしてみるんならええよ。正解と。そう
や話に最初に正解を教えてもらってでその
トレーニングになるのか思考能力のへん
やろ。だからあいうコンピューター
によって教育をするというのはとんでも
ないマリアで日本はダメになっちまうよ。
基本を停滞させてきたのっていうと政治家とかま、官僚とかその辺の方たちがま、責任者というか該当者だと思うんですけど、
[音楽]
その方たちは偏主修主催なんですかね。
うん。そう、そう、そう。みんな偏差修正やないか。
政治家に関してもそう思いますか?
うん。そう思う。だから野党はみんな質問するしから非常にこう野党の言うこと聞いとると戦術的やろ。今がどうのこうのばっかり言っとるやん。与党の方はまだ戦略的をね。
将来にちゃんとするためにということを
言うんやけど、野党は言うことやないか、
あれがいかんよね。政治家はリーダーなん
だから官僚もリーダーなんだから戦略的に
ものを考えることができなきゃダめや。
外チャンネルとかで校長が大償言葉をあの
肯定的文脈で使ってらっしゃったんです
けどうん。学賞って世間的には悪いことだ
と思うんですよね。
[音楽]
学代償が悪いというのは殺される側の理論
だ。だけど殺される側っていうのは恐怖で
ものを考えとるんだからうまくいかんよ。
殺す側の理論やったら怒りでものを考え
とるんだから。これこっちの方が戦略的に
はうまくいくんだね。だから学将っていう
のは今それこそジャイアンみたいなな
いじめてばっかりおる[音楽]人間のこと
を今言っとるじゃん。
だけど昔のガキ大将って俺は優しかったんやで。
リーダーって感じなんですね。[音楽]
リーダーであれこそね、強いものは優しいを実際に表しとったね。だからキ大将になれるぐらいの人間、強い人間。これは優しいということや。今はね、情けないやを優しいって言うんや。だけど情けないやつは優しくないよ。ちょっと自分にガを及ぶと返ったこ願えるぞ。
[音楽]
殺す側の理論っていうのがちょっと誤解を招くかもしれないんでちょっと
1回解説いただいてもいいですか?
[音楽]
うん。殺される側というのは弱い方ということ。殺す側っていうのは強い方ということ。だから強いものの理論は正しいけども弱いものの理論は間違っとる。なぜならば強いものは怒りで行動する。弱いものは恐怖で行動するからね。
校長が繰り返し強いことが正しいことだから強くなれっていうメッセージをよくおっしゃると思うんですけど
[音楽]
偏差修に最後に一言いただいてもいいですか?
どうしても偏差修はね共満というのはええことだ。実力があるからんのが傲慢。
[音楽]
実力がないのにいっが共だから。まずね、
いろんなとこで行動をして、特に人間関係
の[音楽]行動やね、それを繰り返して、
で、しかもいじめられる側に行って
[音楽]でトレーニングしろよ。そうし
たら多少はようになる